[Музика]
привіт, так, ствердно процитовано -
про маленький дирижабль лаваша так,
це не сопрано між одним із
ключових синдромів з хвилиною, коли ти просто
миєшся - отже, це час, коли журавлі приходять
щонайменше на літературу на
маневрах Robo crasher lien  суперник - це
просто футбол, але це просто риба для
вас, що таке жирні copa dos речі, які
ви думаєте, що вам краще сховатися, ви
дивіться, це суспільство, де куля
відвідала L, відчула тут
[Музика]
привіт, хлопці, настав час для уроку англійської,
моє ім'я  Наталія давайте почнемо
і я хотів би сьогодні привітати моїх дорогих
гостей, тому давайте почнемо з вас
привіт ах як ти привіт я добре і
ти я фантастичний
дуже дякую мені треба піти Яна
як справи сьогодні  Я добре, так, це
правильно, ви можете сказати супер-пупер правильно
добре, це краще, добре, тому давайте розпочнемо
наш урок сьогодні, назва нашого уроку
сама по собі,
добре, тому ми продовжимо говорити про
фільми і, сподіваюся, сьогодні ми поговоримо
про пісні  трохи добре, так що давайте рухатися
давайте переглянемо типи фільмів, скажімо, що
номер один – це пригоди до наукової
фантастики, три анімаційний мультфільм номер
чотири комедія, наступний – західна
драма, у нас є історичні
фільми жахів та детективи, я хотів
би запитати вас, який ваш улюблений мій
улюблений  мультфільм все одно правильний
детектив мм-хм, а пригоди - це комедія,
винахід - це комедія, добре, я
знаю, що з тобою, що тобі подобається, моя
улюблена була б комедія.
інші так, це фантастично, якщо ви запитаєте
мене особисто, я також люблю комедії,
і мені дуже подобаються історичні фільми,
насправді це дуже приємно дивитися, тому що
ви можете правильно навчитися, ви можете отримати багато
інформації, тому давайте пограємо в гру,
зробіть нічні ігри так  звичайно, про яку гру,
вибачте, ми говоримо так,
це гра, не хвилюйтеся, тому у мене є повідомлення,
і нам потрібно розшифрувати повідомлення,
тому це тип фільму, який у вас
є j  колись бачила комедія західна драма
історична, тому вам потрібно вгадати, що це
таке, і я допоможу вам, щоб номер один міг
бути B або C, тому давайте зробимо це разом,
я допоможу вам, тому це код, який я
знаю, я хочу, щоб я це пояснив
так  дозвольте мені пояснити це нашим
студентам, тож це код, очікування на
додаткові завдання буде складнішим,
тому це код, і один може бути
правим B або C, а як щодо п'яти виконавчих
правих, це C EF def, ми повторимо це
і  останній XYZ XYZ Браво, тому
насправді, коли ми дивимося, коли ми дивимося
на код, ми виглядаємо так і намагаємося
прочитати слова, щоб вам було
легше вгадати слово, як ви зрозуміли,
що це комедія, тому що,
можливо, номер C  так, тому що у нас немає жодного
стилю з a або B так, ми щойно бачили
так, тому це перша ознака для вас,
і, ймовірно, чому, тому що у нас
немає інших не так, що починається з X
або просто Y так  C і так, це
комедія, і це працює як ця комедія, а
потім ви з'єднуєте таке слово, так
що  sy давай спробуємо ще раз так добре давайте подивимося,
хто буде першим і чи пам'ятаєш ти,
що в школі ти піднімаєш
руку
добре давайте я просто хочу подивитися, як все
буде вперше добре давайте спробуємо
так цей добре Яна була першою,
можливо, це  Вестерн саме тому, що у нас
є вісім V і W, ми не маємо
нічого, що починається на v праворуч на
W, так що вестерн, що з цього приводу, це
дуже коротке слово,
якщо ви подивитеся на номер два, я не буду давати
вам
драму так  Браво дивно, спасибі, баба,
це драма, вибач, ммм так добре, тому
є завдання для тебе, і я закодував
речення Вау,
тому це для учнів, скопіюйте
код, і я запитаю вас в
кінці уроку, що таке  це
добре, так це справді складно,
добре, тому ми повернемося до цього слайду
в кінці уроку,
так, зараз ви не вгадаєте, тому
це потрібен час, щоб учні підготувалися,
тому я хочу, щоб ви вгадали мій улюблений фільм,
тому  подивись на мене Джеймс, так ми говоримо, місце
вивчати вивчати англійську, точно скажи і
давайте  подивіться на огляд фільму,
я хочу, щоб ви прочитали текст,
тож це стосується останнього фільму «Скайфол,
добре»,
який був випущений в 2012 році, це
вважається найкращим відчуттям Бонда,
щоб погодитися, що це найкращий фільм, який у мене
був  я не бачив одного з них о, ви повинні
прийти, вам потрібно було б подивитись, це
дуже приємно,
добре, тому ми знаємо, що Джеймс Бонд
це спіраль, агент, правильно так, як ми
назвемо його, його номер, вони називають його подвійним,
о сім подвійним  подвійний о сім так так
повторюй за мною подвійний о сім і
будь ласка, сер, так,
мелодію виконала Адель, ти
пам'ятаєш мелодію, що ми, мабуть, ти знаєш
мелодію на тему я знаю Skyfall, так,
це та сама назва  дуже обережно,
тому Адель написала там музика
написала пісню сама, так що сьогодні, і
Джеймс Бонд. О, зазвичай повторюємо, я завжди
вибираю фільми, щоб дивитися сам, я завжди
вибираю костюм сам, я завжди
вибираю автомобіль сам, тому він все робить
сам, тому сьогодні ми  поговоримо про
трохи драматизувати, і це будуть
зворотні займенники reflexive, це
роздуми про мене, добре, і для цього давайте
переглянемо предметні займенники об’єктні займенники
присвійні прикметники та зворотні
займенники
це як учитель, що це добре, дозвольте мені
допомогти вам так предметні займенники
Хто я, ми говоримо  ах ах так я маю на увазі, ти
знаєш, якщо ми з тобою, ми говоримо
так точно, і ти був тим, що сказала вона
точно, і це Браво, це легко,
і я розмовляю з тобою, вони, наприклад,
студенти розповідають про нас, вони кажуть,
що вони точно  так, і всі разом
ми ми Браво,
так що це підмет займенники суб'єкт
також перекладається як пігмент, тому суб'єкт
я людина, яка робить речі, які я люблю, він
любить вона дивиться добре суб'єкт, отже,
дія давайте з об'єктними займенниками
об'єкт це не я це  мені
так запереч мені я не роблю сам
це те, що хтось робить зі мною О для
мене
для нього так браво для неї так так добре
так це знову це тема я
роблю дію об'єкт
я не роблю щось  ody do it for me okay
присвійні прикметники так що маркер
мій о, такий присвійний означають, що це
належить мені, тому маркер мій, о він,
Браво маркер впевнений, що це те
саме це, наприклад, котячий будинок так,
ми зазвичай називаємо колодки
їж, щоб котячий будиночок або котяча іграшка
добре, це іграшка, яку ти хочеш, або твоя,
так, твоя, коли це твоє.
чий це маркер, і ви
просто кажете одне слово «твоє», воно стає
присвійним займенником, тому ми використовуємо s
okay yeah what about them
there are they are and we are yes yes our marker
okay і, нарешті, зворотні займенники, тому
це для мене для мене, я такий покірний
рефлексивний це підмет і це
об’єкт, тому зворотний займенник підмет і
помаранчевий однакові, тому я пишу
сам я пишу сам о, я готую
сам або я як можу я можу допомогти
собі я можу зробити це без будь-якої
сторони добре, тому ми  скажімо, я маю на увазі мій
рефлексив  буду собою sama yaro blue
sama
Yara blue sama сам він сам Браво
так, це легко, це також добре,
мм-хм, і подивись так, сам, так,
коли зроби це, тому що я можу поговорити з тобою,
Яна, ти єдина людина, тому я
можу попросити вас допомогти собі, тому що
ви одні, але якщо я розмовляю з вами
обома, то стає дві людини, тому я кажу
себе, тому що є
багато людей, не більше одного, добре,
вони самі виглядають тьмяною сумою,
так, тому що ми  можуть сказати
самі, тому що
вони вже багато значать і ми
самі не ми самі
себе добре, тому давайте подивимося
на картинку і перевіримо, чи правильно
перевірте мене так, я думаю, що так, у
мене є лише одна версія, але ми можемо мати
боса випивки, добре, самі  і ви самі
так зворотні займенники знову я сам
він сам вона себе це сама ви, щоб
ми могли створити реп так іди, зроби це зараз
так я був каже він сам
вона сама це це продає тобі сам w  e
ми самі, вони самі
бурхливі оплески Браво, хлопці, тому я завжди вибираю
фільми для перегляду сам, чи можете ви навести
пропущений приклад з вона вона завжди
вибирає не вмивається.
Браво
Яна, ви можете спробувати з нами, ми завжди
вибираємо фільми, щоб дивитися самі Брава
подивіться самі слова our
це вимовляється як ah like ourselves
yes ourselves yes yourself yes yes Браво добре,
тож давайте ще раз подивимося на текст
і знайдемо там приклади зворотних
займенників чи можете ви знайти будь-які все
правильно сам фільм добре
хто написав  сама пісня так, сама пісня,
і йде сніг ні ні, я не
думаю, що так добре,
тому давайте переглянемо зворотні займенники, ми
використовуємо зворотні займенники, коли підмет
і об'єкт однакові, і,
як приклади, обгоріться або поріжте
себе, коли ви готуєте  ви можете порізатися
або поранити себе, наприклад,
коли ви потрапили в аварію, якщо на всяк
випадок, добре, або у когось це було, ви можете запитати,
чи поранився ви, добре,
все гаразд?  насолоджуватися може бути й про кулінарію
, а також насолоджуйся чи ти
насолоджуєшся зараз так так, звичайно, це
добре
поводися ти так добре, коли
мама посилала учнів до школи, вони кажуть,
поводься добре,
сам або сам так, я
так  я сам мені нічого не потрібно я
не хочу бути так,
почувай себе як вдома, що це
означає, я відчуваю себе як затишно,
комфортно,
добре, так що розслабся, насолоджуйся, ти б
у гуртожитку ах так добре
і допомагай собі так так  це схоже на
те, що ти єдиний
твій друг
вода допоможи собі, так що зроби це
сам, добре, давайте потренуємося, у
нас є речення, які потрібно заповнити
прогалини,
тож можу я подивитися в журнал, щоб побачити,
що є в кінотеатрі, безперечно допоможи собі
Браво, я щойно подивився, так, і я
хочу побачити цю нову наукову фантастику
f  І я теж, давайте підемо завтра, ми можемо запитати
Кейт, чи хоче вона піти з нами, я
не думаю, що вона буде насолоджуватися
годинами, вона сама так, дякую, Боб,
тому вона не може терпіти наукову фантастику, що
означає постійність і емоції, які
мотивують  ммм-хм,
так їй це зовсім не подобається, вона це ненавидить
, добре,
ми можемо поїхати самі. Браво, мій брат
і його друзі вдень самі везуть машину,
і
я впевнений, що вони підвезуть нас
це чудово, давайте зустрінемося у вас вдома о
15:00  Ден, це як далек,
ми можемо спробувати прочитати діалог, добре,
добре, давайте спробуємо, так вуаля,
ким ти хочеш бути Обі, так що Яна,
будь добре, добре, я не маю, давайте спробуємо
склянку, чи можу я подивитися на цей журнал  подивитись,
що відбувається в кіно дивовижно
, допоможіть собі. Я щойно подивився
там сам, і я хочу подивитися той новий
науково-фантастичний фільм, я поїхали
завтра ми не можемо запитати Кей ми можемо запитати
Кейт, чи хоче вона піти з
я не думаю, що їй сподобається вона
витримує науково-фантастичні фільми добре,
до побачення я скажу собі, тоді мій
брат і його друг візьмуть
машину і самі вдень
я впевнений, що там я дам  нас підвезуть
так, я впевнений, що вони підвезуть нас,
що таке ліфт,
вони допоможуть ліфту добре, давайте
закінчимо каркас, тому що я впевнений, що я допоможу
вам з ліфтом, який чудово, давайте
зустрінемося у вас вдома о 3  :00 Гей, MA,
у цьому випадку справжня година, коли у вас
є машина, тому вона завантажена правильно,
так, подивіться, якщо у вас є  машина, яку
людина дістала до
вас, їдьте зі мною, тому я вас підвозю,
ви їдете зі мною на машині добре добре
витривалість
це була Ximena добре, тому вони підвезуть нас
добре, можливо, не швидкість з таким, щоб дати так
напишіть це  це дуже гарна фраза,
тож тепер ще одне завдання для вас і для наших
студентів, так, тому відчуваючи
відповідний зворотний займенник, у вас є
шість речень, я даю вам 15 секунд,
почуваєтеся добре, тому я питаю вас зараз, хлопці, що
є номером один для самих дівчат
ти можеш прочитати всю фразу, щоб вона
вела себе під час фільму браво
добре що можеш спробувати
другий я купив я купив собі квиток, щоб
побачити свою улюблену групу браво
номер три Яна коли була в
Голлівуді вона зробила знаменитого режисера
Timber Wow, так, команда Barden, це так, ніби
я хочу піти і побачити його, Вава,
вона сама гарно закрутила музику
наступного, Яна, побачимося пізніше, дівчата,
насолоджуйтесь,
так, дівчата, так, мм-хм,
це багато  Я і для вас під час останнього
перегляду ми перейдемо до старшого про
себе так, самі
дивовижно, це було дуже добре, ніжно, так
легко,
тому настав час вікторини, це означає, що
я перевірю, що ви готові, тому це
невеликий тест, це  як проблема,
коли вчитель питає вас, я прочитав це ні, добре,
ви можете випити чаю, допоможіть собі.
Браво, давайте спробуємо з цим, яким вони
насолоджувалися в кінотеатрі, о-о,
правильно, два-три самі, Браво
і ще одна Люсі, веде себе цілий день, це
вона
це включно один два три дивовижно,
це ідеальне поєднання
учнів. Я хочу проводити урок з
вами кожен день, тому тепер настав час для гри
знову готовий, так, і для цієї гри нам
знадобиться кубик, кубик, кубик, кубик, ви можете назвати
його кубом  але краще сказати кубик дозвольте
мені написати слово я бачу кубики Браво,
і це можна використовувати для множини,
а також багато кості або один вмирає, ви можете
сказати так само іноді люди кажуть кубик
і багато кубиків, але в наш час вони кажуть, що просто
кубик добре
тож давайте подивимося на це номер один
буду сам собі троє
сам собі
п'ять годин на південь, шість, їм подобається
ця гра, тому ні, ні, вам не потрібно
пам'ятати, ви даєте мені приклад,
наприклад, я написав пісню сам, так що
виглядає так, я кидаю кістки я  мати
число, наприклад, 6 6 означає себе, і мені
потрібно створити речення, використовуючи
себе, їм сподобалося або
вони самі написали пісню
добре, давайте спробуємо, тому я кидаю кістки
– це s 3, тож давайте з ba ba, добре,
важливо зробити  зніми сам так Браво
зроби це сам зняв два фільми так давайте
спробуємо з тобою Яна гарна цифра для
себе вуаля будь ласка, поводься пристойно, коли ти
сидиш тут, це була не
вчителька, вона шкода,
добре, давайте спробуємо ще раз - добре,
Jahna
[Музика]
зроби свій день добре ти можеш сказати
так добре добре можливо Яна
ще раз п'ять п'ять ми самі прийшли
сюди так,
ви що ви їдете за кермом або те, що я
йшов так, це приємно
ходити дуже здорово, погодьтеся,
щоб  Є нічия, але Омаха синяк
бах, тому ми говоримо нічия або краватка
гольф лікар, тому є нічия або краватка
добре,
ми не кажемо Франція, вона народилася так, тому що
це був би переклад з вашої рідної
мови, як жеребкування, як ваша  малюємо так
малюємо малюємо або краватку зав'язуємо о мій боже зупинися
добре галстук давай ходімо далі
чи пам'ятаєш ти попереднє завдання
з початку уроку ой ой так
скажи ну, якщо ми ще раз подивимося код,
щоб, я думаю, наші учні могли  допоможіть
нам і Х'юстон тут
у нас проблема фільм сімнадцять тринадцять тринадцять
так
Аполлон 13 ми відомий актор Форрест
Гамп так той, хто прийшов повісити якийсь
будинок так Браво, щоб ми могли привітатися, Том
Хенкс, сподіваюся, ви добре, тому, хлопці, ваша
домашня робота  добре, на наступному уроці
складіть власні речення, використовуючи зворотні
займенники, і висушіть їх, ви можете
написати від п’яти до десяти речень,
наприклад, Івонна вела себе добре цілий
тиждень, ви самі готуєте вечерю
або інші приклади, і наступного разу я
збираюся  перевірити домашнє завдання
готовий, на жаль, є дзвіночок, і
ми повинні зупинити урок Дякую,
фантастичні студенти, ви фантастичний
вчитель Пітер, дякую, людина, побачимось
наступного разу, моє бачення – це
професійне шоу, більше агентства, щоб
мене ще більше бити,
так, тому що у Розалі є півень  -
як учора ввечері, так, крик Зборнак,
так, Румунія виросла стрічка актори
національний автобус basta YT Ponte запалює
Моріс Лі, який ви знаєте, що є
рівний власний кисень будь-який відвідувач, який ви можете з'їсти
так надмірно ануїтетну валюту, яку він
записав, так що найбільше з Ніколь
Честер  група на Кубі Tonkin серйозна,
особливо коли ви кажете, що це так, так,
камбуз Крішни так двічі є туманністю
аль-Асад ні так, ми до аналізу на опіати,
так як рік, що більше
ESP пристрій - або їдальня відео розсудливість показати
їм інструмент так  твій день Данила